[Musik]
1999 drängen die lawinen in den alpen
bis in die dörfer vor
das hatten die einheimischen seit einem
halben jahrhundert nicht mehr erlebt die
meisten von ihnen noch nie und wer
wirklich im nachhinein kommen sage alles
richtig macht alles klar gemacht aber es
ist wirklich eine aktion aufgefüllt es
kamen tausende lawinen innerhalb weniger
tage
einzelne erreichten im talgrund orte wo
niemand sie erwartet hätte im walliser
dorf evelyn begrub eine lawine neun
menschen unter sich
[Musik]
die großfamilie neben passiert ist sind
die große lawine vom bund vom deutschen
tal voller patrol und dann seitlich
endlich digital bits lesen spät jetzt
ist die ganze sportart die sich
wunderbar mit sind leer
wir hatten ihre nebengewässer
der ganze alpenraum war betroffen vom
italienischen aostatal über die schweiz
bis ins österreichische galtür
zum ersten mal waren nicht nur
einheimische sondern vorwiegend
touristen unter den opfern
[Musik]
wir möchten unser mitgefühl und unsere
anteilnahme zum ausdruck bringen
das war ein wechselbad der gefühle auf
der einen seite sehr viele
vorverurteilungen die gänzlich
unberechtigt waren auf der anderen seite
ein hohes maß an unterstützung ein hohes
maß an solidarität
es war ein schicksalhafter moment die
einen waren mit ihrem auto zu schnell
unterwegs
die anderen zu spät in evelyn wurden
fünf feriengäste vier franzosen und ein
schweizer in ihrem chalet begraben
das letzte foto vom kleinen edgar und
seiner mutter delfinen
zweieinhalb stunden später waren die
beiden tot
der franzose jean lee corp verlor seine
ganze familie martin meine frau delfin
meine tochter entkam ein enkel und eric
und schwyz die
sicherheitsverantwortlichen von d wollen
wurden wegen fahrlässigkeit angeklagt
und verurteilt
das war in der schweiz noch nie
vorgekommen
ich habe ein ziemlich ruhiges gewissen
das ist das wichtigste
[Musik]
seit dem historischen lawinenwinter ist
viel geschehen
wir wollen heute halten stahl netze den
schnee in den hängen des dort übrig hier
hatte sich die todbringende lawine am 21
februar 1999 gelöst
[Musik]
sie riss ein bewohntes sowie elf
evakuierte oder leerstehende chalets mit
sich
verschüttete zwei straßen nichts konnte
sie aufhalten
auch diese schlucht nicht
bis dahin hatten die bergbewohner solch
extrem große lawinen stets als schicksal
hingenommen
nun wurde in evelyn erstmals die frage
nach der schuld gestellt
wie schwer sich die leute von evelyn mit
dieser frage tun lässt die unscheinbare
und namenlose gedenktafel für die
lawinenopfer erahnen
für die gemeindepräsidentin von evelyn
ist der lawinenwinter 99 fern und nah
zugleich 90 war ich zehn jahre alt
ich war daheim mit meiner familie
plötzlich wurde es schwarz
wir hatten keine elektrizität mehr wir
wussten nicht was passiert war
wir warteten aber das licht kam nicht
zurück erste anderen morgen erfuhren wir
die schreckliche nachricht
wir kannten einige der opfer später an
dem tag brachten unsere eltern uns zum
ort wo die lawine gekommen war
wir hatten es im fernsehen gesehen aber
wir konnten nicht glauben dass dies bei
uns passiert war
zwei tage nach dem unglück kommen bagger
zum einsatz
dennoch gab sony corp die hoffnung nicht
auf dass seine familie noch lebte
es sind solche bilder die das dorf in
der wahl der jahrelang verfolgten in den
jahren darauf hatten viele leute
zweifeln
sie informierten sich bevor sie kamen es
war schwierig aus evelyn wieder eine
winter destination zu machen
noch vor wenigen jahren wenn man auf
google wollen eingabe kann man direkt
auf das tragische ereignis sicher dieses
gehört zu unserer geschichte
aber das darf nicht alles sein zu wollen
im winter auch im österreichischen
galtür sind die hänge heute gut gegen
lawinen gesichert auch hier erinnert
eine tafel an die truppen
im gegensatz zu wollen sind sie alle mit
namen aufgeführt
die gries kogel lawine zerstörte einen
ganzen dorf teil und verschüttete 31
menschen
wir wollen sahen auch hier die
verantwortlichen die katastrophe nicht
kommen
noch nie war eine so grosse lawine von
diesem jahr abgegangen
auch dieses dorf war nach dem unglück
nicht mehr dasselbe
peter model war schon damals
bürgermeister von galtür
das ereignis hat unsere dorfgemeinschaft
durchaus verändert es waren gerade die
ersten jahre danach jahre in denen wir
unwahrscheinlich stark zusammengehalten
haben wir haben gemeinsam an zielen
gearbeitet wir haben gemeinsam geschaut
dass wir dieses ereignis überwinden
können
es hat das durch das dorf natürlich auch
in seinem aussehen stark verändert im
dorf hat es neue lawinenschutz bauern
gegeben und im dorf hat es auch diese
spezielle gebäude das alpin ali um
gegeben dass in eine schutzmauer
integriert ist
trotzdem 17 toten die es in der schweiz
gab räten die ehemaligen
sicherheitsverantwortlichen von einer
erfolgreichen bewältigung des labilen
winters 99 so auch charlie wi you der
damalige müssen katastrophe im kanton
wallis
es ist ein unglaublicher thurk waldsee
ist das natürlich schade ich hab ihn
dann in dem es nicht so gut kann und wie
wichtig ist ein sehr würdiger dixie lage
den fall freiwillig aber so unglaublich
wie ich halte die wienerin partie
gezeigt was wir aber gar nicht wovon sie
sind für die ganze pracht in gewinnzone
das ist natürlich in der volks und
edelmetall ist geblieben
abgesehen von den tragischen ereignissen
in wollen gab es für den obersten
lawinenschutz im kanton wallis keine
wirklichen überraschungen
die lawinen kamen dort wo er sie
erwartet hatte
[Musik]
paulis rouwen hennings und es nun sagt
schlawiner sind über die grenze
wir brauchen
damals sind wir natürlich habe den
ziemlich rau straße fast sämtliche blaue
zone evakuiert
und das ist natürlich schon komplett
zerstört wurde sind und 140 sind zum
teil zerstört worden und das thema trixi
[Musik]
unglaubliches glück hatte der junge
bergführer peter schritte gehabt und mit
ihm das ganze walliser bergdorf platten
hier ging die grad lawine nieder es war
die grösste lawine im gesamten alpenraum
es mutet wie ein wunder an dass es keine
toten gab
der moment um ihr alter beruf tätig
geworden ich hebe ich stand und dem ort
und zwar genau zu der monatlichen
abkommen ist maximal medizinischer
notfall wie ich hier bewundert haben wir
mit dem red ist kolleg und genau punkte
hätten wir das wohngeld das heim
deutlichkeit und dann hat man das gefühl
dass ramelow prima oder gehört der wahl
geweben türen und will dublin schnee war
nicht ihr muss ich erst in der letzter
in der letzten sekunde haben und
plötzlich wie ein fisch durch den
anblick zero und dann habe ich nur noch
dem kollegen nicht einfach hier hinter
ekström lag wurde vom tv nur nach einer
partie die grad lawine löste sich auf
einer höhe von 3000 metern
sie war vier kilometer breit die
höchsten anderes stellen bis acht meter
hoch mittel kann der biss sicherer oder
oder hat massa der ikea station ak 11 8
nichts die lawine riss 45 gebäude mit
sich in die tiefe
dass es keine toten gab war der
mustergültigen evakuierung durch den
neuling peter schmidt zu verdanken die
gemeinde platten hatte damals noch
keinen lawinen dienst im liniendienst es
nicht in allen gemeinden weniger die
entstand automobilgeschäft vor der ware
geräte station
oktober laxey und die eigentlich durch
das über demand präsidentin aufgeboten
worden
und wie fast immer um die situation und
nach hat man ja natürlich ist der grund
sei erkenntnisse gebracht hätten
eigentlich dexia als - eine lawine
dienst als - es passiert natürlich ist
das sind darüber eigentlich im außenraum
nötig und wenn wir jetzt einfach die
große lawine an der griff verkaufen das
ereignis armenien ist es richtig losgeht
das hat natürlich
länder
[Musik]
nachdem lawinenniedergängen war charlie
wi you wer unterwegs denn je zuvor
dort wo die großen lawinen gekommen
waren wünschten die menschen nun
schutzmaßnahmen dass pedro kannte ich
dass dies eher noch an die gebäude sind
und dass die also auch schon gesagt
entern die bevölkerung was die jetzt
sehr dringend schutz brauchen
psychologische messewesen
in den beiden gemeinden biel und
zeltingen wurde charlie wi you mit
ungeduld erwartet nach dem niedergang
der lawine fühlten sich die leute
bedroht
der gemeindepräsident von selb ihnen hat
der haus und werkstatt verloren so große
spricht dass das die lawine durch
gestoppt und wenn sich die lawine
vitalität und richtig berge und täler
richtig selbst das durch was hat die
truppe das war sicher zur hälfte
ausgleichstor das mit einer schnee muss
und mit so viel feuchtigkeit video im
schnee strickt sie das was wir die
stärken die billige tal lawine weckte
erinnerungen an die tragödie von 1827
damals waren 52 menschen in den
schneemassen begraben worden
auch wenn es diesmal glimpflich
ausgegangen war
es musste nun ein schutz er unbedingt
will
das ist sieben cent auf das heißt mal
runter das selbstgewählte rennt oder und
das meister ab
was mich sehr beschäftigt gerade für
familien denn eine große freude wenn
jeden tag frische schutz in der
schwangerschaft bzw
die sorge um die sicherheit der dörfer
ließ ein altes projekt aufleben den bau
zweier dimmel der mann dort falsche zeit
gibt es geht es vermutlich nur eis und
aus dem bambi uhr und der war mir
natürlich komplett übersetzt und der
kontraktlogistik und aber ich dachte
jetzt klären oder
schließlich darf man sich gar nicht um
hilfe eines verbrechers ist das normal
der batterie der behörden mit
im sommer 99 waren die
sicherheitsverantwortlichen des kantons
und der gemeinden wollen oft gemeinsam
im lawinengebiet unterwegs andreas war
da bereits seit 20 jahren chef des
lawinen dienstes die dinge haben sich
verändert
es ist vielen klar geworden dass es
lawinen zonen braucht so wie sie
übrigens existierten aber alle haben sie
als zu streng kritisiert nun wird klar
man muss die ausnahmefälle ernst nehmen
in den richtigen zone bauen vorsichtig
sein
das braucht ein solches ereignis
es macht allen bewusst was sache ist
[Musik]
wer all die toten hat sich niemals hätte
ich mir das vorstellen können
niemand von uns hätte sich vorstellen
können dass die lawine so weit runter
kommen würde
sie ging über den felsen hinaus das
übertraf alle vorhersagen
das hat mich etwas erleichtert die frage
ob es sich bei den tödlichen
lawinenunfall oder schuld handelte
mussten sich auch die verantwortlichen
von galtür stellen imperium zeigt ein
film was vor 20 jahren geschah
330.000 tonnen schnee draußen mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 350 kilometer pro
stunde auf galtür zu ob man das lawinen
er eigentlich heute erkennen würde
mit den damaligen mitteln das glaube ich
nicht
es war einfach es gab keinen
historischen hinweis in einer gemeinde
die seit 1000 jahren an dieser stelle
existiert es gab einfach keinen hinweis
dass aus diesem bereich zwei dermaßen
große lawinen abgehen können jetzt
wissen wir es matthias einschätzung wird
auch von den gutachtern des schweizer
instituts für schnee- und
lawinenforschung geteilt für die
wissenschaftler war die katastrophe von
galtür ein mysterium
schon bald nach dem unglück reisen
lawinenexperten des slf ins paznauntal
sechs monate lang untersuchen die
forscher in akribischer detailarbeit die
verkettung unglücklicher umstände die zu
dem verheerenden lawinenunglück würde
noch dazu waren seien gerade auch die
fachleute die sich dieses ereignis nicht
vorstellen konnten und die haben uns
dann auch er in schutz genommen und uns
auch verteidigt und haben uns dann
natürlich auch gerade diesen ersten
meter unseres weges ganz wertvoll
gegangen
in seltenen beendete der
gemeindepräsident im laufe des sommers
99 den wiederaufbau seines hauses
zugleich trieb er das projekt der
lawinen den läufern die zeit drängte
noch immer war die angst vor der lawine
groß gestützt auf eine rudimentäre
fotomontage bewilligten die beiden
gemeinden die dämme
aber wenn ihr fast genau so verstanden
ist es sind sicher minute hätte war
man habe deutschland und das kommando
das trifft ja sowieso zu hoch
im herbst kamen dann die ersten bagger
[Musik]
gleiche chance gibt etwas gutes ab ob
die konstante geht hatte ich noch mal
dass bürger wer das kauft die stadt
bielefeld
das produkt ist
jan o
kreis kli
das projekt war gigantisch die maschinen
blieben ganze vier jahre in den dörfern
die stimmigen dort
prinz habe
die maschinen verschoben 150 tausend
kubikmeter erde
die lawine hatte gleich viel schnee
gebracht der gemeindepräsident von
zeltingen war am ziel auch persönlich
sein haus war nun durch eine wand aus
alarmierten beton gesichert und auch vom
anfänglichen zusammenhalt im dorf der
hilfsbereitschaft war nicht viel übrig
geblieben
wilfried fischer unterstufe massiv ist
auch schön ich mir nur die die planer
und das ziel bürger kommen so nico dass
sich die geräte will vom die information
war sie beim essen geprüft
und wer den anspruch nach
[Musik]
ungleich schweres zu verarbeiten
man kann nicht ständig sagen es geht
einem schlecht die leute erwarten etwas
anderes und wenden sich ab
am anfang warnt man vor den anderen aber
mit der zeit lernt man dass man die
tränen für sich behalten muss
für ihn war der verlust seiner familie
nicht schicksal
er ist selber richter mit der
einschätzung des walliser
untersuchungsrichters war er nicht
einverstanden
für ihn war die lawine vorhersehbar
auch wenn ich momente große ermutigung
verspüre denke ich dass es eine art
moralische pflicht ist nicht locker zu
lassen
er vertiefte sich in die geschichte der
lawinenniedergänge von evelin daraufhin
reichte er seine klage ein
es gab bereits 1977 eine lawine am tor
die brücke die bis an den fuß des
felsens reichte also wenige meter vom
talent war mein problem ist
25 jahre später nachzuweisen ob die
gemeindebehörden die nötigen
vorkehrungen getroffen haben um die
häuser in die gefahrenzone vor diesen
lawinen zu schützen
mit jeffrey combs klage begann eine
jahrelange juristische
auseinandersetzung um die frage
schicksal oder schulter liu begleitete
den angeklagten zu jeder verhandlung für
ihn ist das urteil bis heute
unverständlich
herr labbadia unter dem urteil hat mehr
solide fast nix das ist ein wort
korrigiert aber vermietet unter deinen
standen und diese klar gehört dazu
geführt dass unwahrheiten verbreitet
wurde
das ist wohl ein zeichen unserer zeit
dass man einen schuldigen finden ist
käßmann habe die leute an orten bauen
lassen wo man nicht so aber der bauherr
teodoro war kein fremder sondern einer
aus
die gemeinde wollen ließ als eine der
ersten gemeinden der schweiz eine
gefahrenkarte erstellen
1973 sah diese am ort des
lawinenniedergang so aus rot bedeutet
höchste lawinengefahr bauen ist nicht
erlaubt
in der blauen zone ist die gefahr
geringer und bauen erlaubt vorausgesetzt
die häuser werden mit einer animierten
betonwand verstärkt
[Musik]
1977 wurde der gefahren plan revidiert
die rote zone warnung kleiner die blaue
größer das ermöglichte den bau des
chalet teodoro diese standen mitten in
der blauen zone und nicht mehr an der
grenze zu ägypten 19 93 wiederholte sich
das prozedere noch mehr rot wurde zu
blau und damit lawinen land zu lukrativ
im bauland nach dem unglück stellte sich
heraus dass charlie teodoro war ohne die
obligatorische schutzmauer aus
halbierten beton errichtet worden dass
charlie dort oben hätte vielleicht
wieder standen wenn es aus beton gewesen
wäre
die lawine kam nicht schnell denn der
schnee war schwer mit viel masse aber
verlangsamt
man hätte nur das erdgeschoss aus beton
fahren müssen
das holz darüber hätte es mit genießen
die leute waren ja unten im wohnzimmer
als die lawine kam aber von diesen
dingen wurde nie geredet
das ist doch erstaunlich man hat bloß
dem architekten die frage gestellt es
war verjährt das war's
wie sehr können im dritten jahr des
mauerbaus die angst vor der lawine war
längst dem ärger über den lärm und den
staub gewichen
wenn man das gerät und sicher nicht
begriffen dass das dass man gott also
das land verschont und missbraucht und
die haare hält sich gold sieht nur dass
die handtaschen und der was somit nur
machen den schnuller aller danach um
grobe beteiligt sind im winter 2002
mussten die andere uns ausziehen
der antrag sieht ja denken sie denn
und konnte stufe ist der katastrophe
dass der
[Musik]
an der ecke ins haus war zum abbruch
bereit über die höhe der entschädigung
war ein zermürbender streit ausgebrochen
das standort und die natur wachsen die
situation dort natur bin ich gar nicht
das ist natur und das passiert überall
und über all das würden wir sind überall
messen müsse jetzt aber nicht ganz klar
ob situation von vor der mannschaft von
der man stromer das ist problem mit
internet oder
binden erklärt axel schäfer der mann
hoch das ist schöneberger das ist
[Musik]
seit der damm steht sind die dörfer zwar
sicherer geworden aber auch kälter schon
am frühen nachmittag wird der große
billiger damm lange schatten über das
dorf
der gemeindepräsident von sell klingen
weist jede kritik von sich
250 tote sind dem motto ob sie und die
haben ihre streife das ist die normale
katastrophe gar was ich nicht hoffe aber
dass moderne immer die beste wahl für
mich gehört vermutlich unerwidert bis
zur montage nicht viel höher weil es
nicht aber es ist alles der axima jetzt
reicht s p c verdrängt
man hat mit der bühne zone mit allem ist
man über spezielle rundgang
das sind vielleicht findet sich von der
natur ich sage immer die natur die gc in
sotschi will einfach dem zurück die
liegenschaft allerhand war es ist und
das müssen wir noch sehen
die jährliche prozession zum gedenken an
die lawinentoten von 1827 konnten die
dämme nicht zum verschwinden bringen
jetzt wurden die so groß die lawine dem
hemd meldet auch die prozession nach
alter brauch messen
wozu denn
ja ja doch sehr im müll menge die damen
sie hier schutz
diese schützen kräftig unter den
herrgott z
ach und zu kunden und denen nichts unter
hunden gibt
die lawine von evelyn löste sich in
einer höhe von knapp 3000 metern als
staub lawine in den tieferen lagen riss
sie nassen schnee mit sich dass sie
durch die tiefe schlucht und sogar über
den felsen hinaus dringen würde
dafür gab es in ihr wohl ähnlich wie in
galtür keine gesicherten historischen
hinweisen in evelyn existierte jedoch
eine gültige gefahrenkarte diese stützte
sich nicht auf historische lawinen
ereignisse sondern war durch eine
computersimulation berechnet worden
für die einschätzung des gerichts
gutachtens war sie dennoch entscheidend
weil ich denke da ist man bereit sind
das skript oder luftfahrt der theke ist
yahoo stark war und das sind 1 k
die rabbiner gefordert bestätigt worden
ist dann muss ich jetzt ganz klar sagen
die lawine ist vorhersehbar
die gefahrenkarte für deutlich diese
einschätzung unvorhersehbar war gemäss
den gutachtern lediglich das ausmaß der
lawine sie was über die rote und blaue
zone hinaus
dort wo die lawine gekommen war ist
bauen heute verboten
die gerichtsverhandlungen dauerten jahre
angeklagt waren der gemeindepräsident
von evelin sowie der chef des lawinen
dienstes der gemeinde anwesend im
gerichtssaal war auch sony corp
es ist umso schmerzhafter weil ist der
sechste jahrestag des unglücks ist seit
2001 186 tagen warte ich auf diesen
prozess zur anklage kamen nicht die
verehrten vergehen wie etwa die fehlende
schutzmauer des chalets theo dohle
sondern lediglich das verhalten der
beiden verantwortlichen am 21 februar
gemäss der gerichtsakten nach andere
georges an diesem morgen tritt auf er
erstellte ein schnee profi und kam zum
schluss dass in evelyn sehr große
lawinengefahr bestand gefahrenstufe 5
das heißt höchste gefahr ja ich glaub
stufe 5 aus es war total außergewöhnlich
regen und der schnee nass bis auf 2000
metern
ich dachte dieser werde die lawine
bremst
das war unvorstellbar dass sie so groß
werden würde
ich hatte in den oberen lagen einige
charlize evakuiert dass die lawine bis
zum tal grund kommen würde war
unvorhersehbar
nachdem er die gefahr festgestellt hatte
traf sich mit dem gemeindepräsidenten
dieser segnete seine maßnahmen ab für
den talgrund wo sich die kantonsstrasse
unterscheidet jude law befanden
beschlossen sie keine massnahmen
verdächtig war eine fahrspur für fisch
und hat dementsprechend müsse die
maßnahme momente gefallen oder release
macht das wäre dass sie das war heute
sehr schwierig vor der straße und der
operation vor der geburt gegen diese
maßnahmen sprachen zwei gewichtige
gründe dass vielen historische hinweise
und die daten der messstationen in und
um wollen
der kette gewinde cheers wenn wir in
dieser zeit bei 50 zentimeter schnee
liegt ist das maxxi museo oder vier
zentimeter das ist ein und bewirkte
möglichkeiten vom kanton hoch geraten
und mit dem wagen stehen seite
stabilisiert und das hat er nicht
gemacht bundes lag und dass die masse
also groß in den volume one ist ihr
system kohl bis zur straße hinter mir
vorstellen
die einwohner von evelyn kannten sich
aus mit lawinen
sie hatten immer wieder verschüttete
geworden allerdings in gebäuden waren
seit über 200 jahren keine menschen von
lawinen getötet worden groß war daher
die ratlosigkeit als am 21 februar die
nachricht von verschütteten häusern
eintraf
martin ist das konzept war wenn was
unternimmt wird strasser schwierige von
der operation erhole was man die
mitbringt im dorf um zwei weitere
maßnahmen werden normales fahrrad und
auch geübt zu schieben ist das nicht wir
gehen diese unterlassung wurden die
beiden verantwortlichen der mehrfachen
fahrlässigen tötung beschuldigt und zu
bedingten gefängnisstrafen und einer
geldbuße verurteilt
möchten sie den gemeindepräsidenten
ich habe ihnen nichts zu sagen
[Musik]
das gab einige jahrestage seit 1999
jedes jahr am 21
februar erinnerte man sich in zwei
sätzen dann die verurteilung
es gibt leute die nicht wissen was sich
ereignet hat
wenn man sagt dass der gemeindepräsident
und der sicherheitschef verurteilt
worden sein
er fasst das nicht das ganze problem
aber man muss damit leben
mein gewissen ist ziemlich ruhig
das ist
[Musik]
der lawinenschutz profitierte vom urteil
von evelyn gefahrenkarten können seither
nicht mehr übergangen werden
dies ändert nichts daran dass das urteil
bei vielen einheimischen insbesondere
den sicherheitsverantwortlichen im
berggebiet auf unverständnis stieß viele
sehen ihre beiden kollegen bis heute als
sündenböcke
die sicherheitsverantwortlichen
verdorrten wollen und wo in der
situation heraus entscheiden die sind
natürlich sehr große emotionen geweckt
das was sie tut argument sie hat einfach
plötzlich nicht mehr christ ich mir
überhaupt gedeckt einem monat ist
passiert wer dreht schlussendlich
wirklich verantwortlich und für was wird
nur wer verurteilt oder wenn man nicht
verurteilt und was kennen vorwerfen und
und obwohl der lawinenstufe haben wir es
mal eigentlich später oder oder sollte
man später alles fragen die sind
plötzlich im remix und sind zum teil
natürlich nicht beantwortet wurde und
wenn es um große unsicherheit entstanden
im österreichischen galtür hatte sich
die schuldfrage nicht gestellt
entsprechend leichter fiel dort die
verarbeitung der tragödie imperium
pflegt man die erinnerung in einem
eigens dafür eingerichteten gedenkraum
einzige mir die frage stellen was war
denn vielleicht die größte leistung auch
unseres dorfes so war es nicht mehr
wieder aufbauen das war auch nicht der
bau des alpin ari um sondern es ist die
freundschaft zu den hinterbliebenen der
opfer vom februar 1999 und es ist schon
etwas besonderes wenn die
hinterbliebenen wieder nach galtür
kommen bei denselben vermietern wollen
aber auch zu mir aufs gemeindeamt kommen
und wir gemeinsam lachen können und
gemeinsam auch einen schnaps trinken
können das ist eine gute bewältigung
holländer ist heute weit was den
lawinenschutz angeht
nach anfänglichem zögern kommen auch die
feriengäste wieder was die bewältigung
der tragödie von damals angeht bleibt
dagegen noch viel zu tun
es wird eine große gedenkmesse geben
auf seite der gemeinde sind wir dabei
die familien der opfer zu befragen
denn es ist sehr schwierig in dem
zusammenhang zu wissen was von gutem und
was von schlechtem geschmack ist aber
wir müssen etwas tun und dafür müssen
wir die betroffenen familien an unserer
seite haben und nicht gegen uns
auch haus bill seltenen gibt
essverhalten gute nachrichten
berta hause hat ihr haus vor einigen
jahren schließlich doch freiwillig
verlassen
seit die dämme stehen haben sich einige
neue familie niedergelassen allerdings
nur in seltenen alt gemeindepräsident
markus walter freut sich darüber
es ist ihm eine späte genugtuung und
rechtfertig den massiven eingriff in die
landschaft
den preis für die sicherheit bezahlt er
gerne dass ich die diskussion wenn man
dem sie ist jetzt nur den minderwert
oder würde uns mehr wasser oder ob
lieber verliebt und eine gesunde ich
komme dass in duissern ansage dass ich
richtig oder die sich richtig aber mache
ich glaube wieder und werden wohl im
schlaf erwiderte gehört habe dass es hat
ja alles riesig aber es enthält nur
durch zwei und dass wir hier so blieb
das wird nie und das war die uni gehört
auf der bieler seite nimmt die
bevölkerung fortlaufend ab die andere
teams sind noch da sie haben ihr neues
haus in sicherer distanz zum damm gebaut
die dann schlussendlich hat es nicht
prüft nie im leben hängt ein kran den
wahlkampf zu ziehen
die hatte der verwalter wettgemacht
ich bin sehr froh dass ich das gemacht
habe und die leser es ist ein schutzwall
selbst nehmen und das ist gut versteckt
darum seitige großereignisse also keine
zerstören wir seit die schutzmacht noch
einen treffer pro spiel ich sich aber
wenigstens der polizei ums alter charlie
wi you genießt seinen ruhestand
er konnte in seinen letzten jahren als
sicherheitsverantwortlicher im wallis
sämtliche lawinen die 1999 die menschen
bedrohten und töteten mit
schutzmaßnahmen sicher
diverse was also wollen wir zum zweiten
mal hinter hat mal viel besser im griff
dieser kreis verantwortlicher viel
besser ausgebildet und man kann aber die
standorte wo christi fall aber seine
passiert obwohl ein gletscher absturz
zeigen wo das stattfindet wird bordeaux
hat nötig ist und seitdem los geht's
natürlich aber große lawine in
wohnsiedlungen sich verwirklichen
das haben wir im griff wird das schon
noch und ich hoffe es
auch die grad lawine oberhalb von
platten ist gezähmt
20 jahre lang hat peter schwitter der
zum regionalen lawinen spezialisten
aufgestiegen ist mit ihr gewohnt
heftig
erst versuchte er sie mit sprengstoff zu
zählen
der einsatz des helikopters zum springen
setzte sich nach dem lawinenwinter 99
allmählich durch wenn auch nur zögerlich
zur bekämpfung der grat lawine gab es
jedoch keine alternative
wo werden im helikopter geschossen der
zweimal bronze situationen kwf das
problem ist ein herrlich zwar super
instrument zum schießen
aber der kommt natürlich nur bei
schönwetter flieger und da wir immer mir
sofort bis ende oktober ist sie also
quasi schneefall und sturm bricht sie
und ihre knochen aufgebaut und das hat
natürlich noch einmal drei tage durch
den schneefall bedeutet dass wir hier
enorm ich nehme mir selbst und das hat
der halter elvis war wurde halt richtig
kanton stars sind und so und dass ich
einfach mehr über hat das einfach nicht
mehr entfernt wurden und nicht nach und
wurden noch nie ins geschehen ganz klar
ob sie vom schicksal hat natürlich
negativ wie ich bin völlig kaputt und
überall kai wollen und alles haben und
es ist nicht einfach
am anfang ist wirklich nicht
in den folgenden jahren tester täter
später immer neue methoden um die
lawinen zu entschärfen
[Musik]
heute ist das springen der lawinen
schweizweit der standort im
lawinenschutz
die wahlstationen mittel zum lavigne
abschießen die möglichkeit mit dem
helikopter werde alles möglich wo wir
jetzt selbst an die keinen organisieren
wir kennen
und das ist natürlich schon viel viel
einfacher und besser als dort im juni
2006 auf den ganzen raum verteilt sind
insgesamt sind es jetzt dritter zentrum
und das war eigentlich der ganze portion
visiers abschießen und mit
lichtempfindlichen kameras aus sicherer
distanz zu überwachen ob die sprengung
erfolgreich war
der neueste schrei ist die überwachung
per radar
das lawine oder hat jetzt natürlich ein
unglaublicher vorteil
das ermöglicht es quasi per der
tagessieg bei jedem wartet erst wenn das
ist unabhängig von der sicht
es sind im klavier trotzen aber trotzdem
wintersturm das würde ich jetzt tor
beteiligt das wird zum beispiel keine
lawine der umziehen wo wir weniger
probleme mit kantonsstrasse und einfach
weniger lied auf der piste oder was auch
immer
nach jeder sprengung kontrolliert peter
später wie viel schnee abgegangen ist
dabei inspizierte auch seine 13 kanonen
richtig stoppen
genau das war
hannover
genauso
das technisch könig brachte schöner
odyssey
als äußerst beliebt ist auch der chef
der boote
beete später setzt große hoffnung auf
diese technik mit ihrer hilfe will er
sowohl das schicksal wie die schuld
eliminieren
das gefühl war der wir in zukunft die
situation besser beherrschen
der letzte winter eigentlich geprägt
wäre ja ein neuer schnee massaker am
letzten winter die große zahl messe und
teil wirklich von seiner damals 80 große
lawine geschossen und hält eigentlich
der ganze winter problemlos überbrücken
ohne große maßnahme evakuation oder
service und das zeigt dass man mit einer
mittel die richtige setzt richtige lied
wurden da sind richtige handhabung bin
ich überzeugt
in der griff hat es ist ein bisserl als
ich eine gewagte aussage will
unterdessen verlassen
das ist alles mit technik verbunden und
technik
und dann war da natürlich im sommer von
stein gebunden
peter schwitter beobachtet den hang tag
und nacht so baut viel schnee gefallen
ist drückt der einen knopf gas strömt in
die kanone
[Musik]